I put myself on tape in Chicago when
there was a massive casting breakdown
that went out and just sent the tape in
and then we got a call they're flying to
Los Angeles to read with Chevy and the
director I mean I was terrified of
course and and I remember I don't know I
don't think it ended up in the script
but there was like a full-page monologue
that rust had and for us yeah I don't it
may have just been for auditioning prom
purposes I'm not sure I think yeah yeah
and and I nailed it and and Chevy said
you're the first one that's been able to
do that without looking at his page or
stumbling a certain a single syllable he
got the part
without talking to the director of the
studio or anything just said you got it
and in hindsight it wasn't because I had
to given any example of comedic chops
but it was probably because it proved to
you that I wouldn't keep you later onset
because I wouldn't mess up my lines but
I was very of course I was intimidated
by the entire environment and yeah I'm
you know I'd grown up you say that
because you were already a good actor
then it was like his talent was later
well thank you and it was a really big
deal to me for all the obvious reasons
but also you know it had really only
done musical theater in Chicago my
father wasn't all that impressed with my
productions of Pippin and Fiddler on the
Roof he was but he was very impressed
that I was in the same room with Chevy
Chase and it was a very big idea and and
I have to tell this story because it
occurs to me often and every time that
I'm on set with with with with with a
kid there was a lunch hour that Chevy
took me I don't think we told anyone he
took me to the sets of Harlem Nights was
shooting at the time and Ghostbusters
two was shooting at the time and we
visited those sets Here I am again like
I've never been in a BMW before yet he
and I are rolling around to these sets
and meeting red Foxx and
and in Richard Pryor and Eddie Murphy
and Harold Ramis and Dan Aykroyd and the
way that they took me in I'll never
forget and I'll never forget thank you
that's very nice
[Applause]